Japan has announced sanctions against
Russia over its actions in Ukraine the
sanctions cover the issuance of Russian
Bonds in Japan and also Target Two
Breakaway Rebel regions in Ukraine
Russian President Vladimir Putin had
recognized their claim to Independence
on Monday Japanese prime minister fumio
kishida announced the Japanese sanctions
earlier today
Japan has decided to impose the
following sanctions
first we will suspend issuing visas to
certain individuals of the two so-called
republics of Donetsk and luhansk and
freeze their assets
second we will introduce important
export bans on the two so-called
Republics
third we will prohibit the issuance and
distribution of Russian Bonds in Japan
should the situation worsen in the
future
we will work with the G7 and other
International communities
to quickly take further actions
join me now for more from Tokyo is
journalist Michael Penn Michael do we
know how or even if these sanctions will
hurt Russia
uh it's pretty clear that these
sanctions will have almost zero effect
and in fact they seem to have been
designed to have almost zero effect so
for example one of the sanctions says
that people from the these uh these
territories in Ukraine will not be able
to have visas to come to Japan or not be
able to trade with Japan well clearly
you know there's not much uh trade
between Donetsk and and Tokyo and right
now almost all foreigners anywhere in
the world can't come into Japan for
because of covet policies so the idea
that they won't issue visas to to people
from that territory is pretty much the
same policy for that the rest of the
world at the moment so they're not
really their sanctions are basically
symbolic to say that they're sanctions
they're clearly designed not to bite not
to have a real effect
so if they are not meant to have the
real effect what is the real reason
behind them
a Tokyo has imposed imposed sanctions uh
in in doing so uh they're sort of making
what they would say is sort of a a moral
statement uh you know on the side of
international legality but the real
reason is because uh you know Japan
wants to keep a very close relationship
with the United States uh it's very
concerned about the rise of China and
it's put strong value on the U.S Japan
Alliance so uh in a sense by keeping uh
close with the United States on the
Russia issue it means that Japan uh can
expect a strong backing from the United
States uh when it has its own security
problems possibly uh in East Asia so
that that would be the real key reason
why Japan is going along with this
uh the the area that you talk about in
East Asia forms to be part of the larger
indo-pacific of which Japan is a key
player and a number of Japanese
diplomats have spoken over the past few
days and they have talked about
following the rules-based international
order because it is applicable not just
in the indo-pacific but also in the case
of Ukraine is that also another
rationale behind this
uh it's certainly uh a reason which a
rationale which they will give and it's
uh part of sort of the let's call it the
Diplomatic posture of Japan it is true
that you know the Japanese society and
Japanese within you know their own
country are generally you know rule
abiding people uh but uh you know I
think that if they found their national
interests served uh by breaking the law
so for example let's say on the issue of
whaling uh they will you know they'll do
so uh but in most cases they they they
present themselves as uh uh rule-abiding
uh and and force for the rule of law in
East Asia in the world
journalist Michael Penn in Tokyo thanks
so much for breaking that down thank you